[Music]  this is a really popular family-friendly  event Aviation Nation returning next  weekend at Nellis Air Force Base it  features air displays some military  pilots and Premier fighting aircrafts  installation Commander Josh demotts  tells us they are very excited to  welcome the community back it's our  first time since the pandemic to get to  open our doors back up and thank our  local community show you what we do out  here on base and it's a lot more than  just make loud noise it's defending our  freedom here in the United States and  we're super excited to have really  hopefully a big crowd come out to base  here  so again this is happening next weekend  next Saturday and Sunday you can park at  the Las Vegas Motor Speedway this is  something you should not miss